you know how much the most expensive
apartment in this city is
one zillion [ __ ] dollars how could a
city like that die
this is the most beautiful place in the
world central park
every day i come here i'm amazed at how
beautiful it is i'm
in a new york state of mine we lived in
a rent control apartment by the park
you know what my mother did to get that
apartment she smothered her sister with
a pillow
she killed her sister for this city yeah
when it hasn't been your day your week
month or even your year but
i'll be there for you before cover and i
had a great [ __ ] job
i used to spit on people in central park
and they'd give me money
you can't get a job like that somewhere
else this is the greatest city there's
opportunities everywhere
jerry seinfeld thinks we're gonna make
it i bet he's right
it's the greatest city in the world baby